I have been tagged in the Google verb
game by Leonardo and for those of you
that don't know what the Google verb
game is I will explain it to you now
basically you take your name which in my
case is Charlie McDonnell you take a
verb also known as a doing word you put
them in some speech marks you type that
into Google and then hilarity ensues
however if I'm gonna be honest I think
the tag games are really really boring
so to liven this one up a little bit I'm
going to incorporate it with another tag
game this is a tag game that I was
tagged in many eons ago and it is called
the naked vlog tag game and because I'm
quite sure that this vlog tag game
doesn't really need explaining I'm going
to jump straight into it are you ready
oh would you look at that it seems I'm
now extremely naked this is suddenly
very awkward okay I do want to see wish
there was a way for me to prove to you
that I am now currently completely naked
but YouTube Terms of Service doesn't
really agree with Willys so I can't do
that I can show you like me there's a
visit me oh this is this is weird well
if my mom walks in I'm just gonna have
to do this really quickly okay Charlie
is so cool like these to come back to
YouTube and blade three seven six needs
to apologize just to kind of explain
that one to you um there was a time when
I was gonna leave YouTube and I'd taken
down all my videos and I was ready to
run away and then I kind of got over
myself
I just came back so here I am on YouTube
hello
Charlie McDonnell looks like a good
hugger I like this one quite a lot and
it's true as well I don't just look like
a good hugger I am one just ask anybody
I am I am classy when it comes to
hugging all of these next ones are from
YouTube drama calm and I thought I
should just let you know none of them
are true YouTube dramas basically a
website run by webmaster trevor riga
where he likes to tell lies about people
for his own amusement charlie is so cool
like says he is gay and has a secret man
crush on David meaning thousands of
charlieissocoollike fangirls are now
disappointed that Charlie is a closeted
homosexual Charlie is so cool like once
youtubers to attend the David YouTube
gathering on August 1st 2008 at 12:00
noon sharp in Leicester Square in London
and
peachie nerimon is not invited you know
invite Alex sorry charlie is so cool
like does product placement
advertisements the Hershey's and
Nintendo which are both well-known huge
sponsors of Google and YouTube and then
fortunately there are no more from
Trevor eager and his crazy little
website after that charlie is so cool
like hates YouTube people nerimon comedy
mobile Facebook phone people charlie is
so cool like asks you to take his mug
that's quite a nice little reference to
one of my old videos that okay my mug
it's it's ergonomically designed on my
old videos are so weird
rubbish charlie is so cool like likes
boobs is utterly straight but has a
secrets charlie eat some dinner
this one isn't actually about me but
anyone who watches my blog TV shows will
know that it's actually pretty relevant
this one says Charlie wears the pants
but then after that it's got our IP so I
don't know apparently my pants are dead
which is quite unfortunate cuz I kind of
need to wear them in a little bit I'm
getting quite cold
Charlie was arrested for maintaining a
disorderly house that is weird
mum stop singing mum
oh she hasn't no respect and then the
last one is charlie is so cool like
loves me and there's actually a photo to
accompany the song because it was found
on deviantART you might be able to see
underneath my comment the comment says
haha I love your mum like I said at the
beginning I think tank games are quite
boring things and be honest you wouldn't
have watched this video unless I was
naked so no I'm not gonna be tagging
anybody but that only applies to the
Google verb game alright if anyone wants
to post video responses of the nakeds
please be my guest are you making it
like this yeah it's naked vlog tech game